retour en images sur un week-end
politique marquée par les tensions avec
flora sauvage
dernière ligne droite avant le premier
tour le 10 avril avec le lancement de la
campagne officielle ce lundi c'est la
stricte égalité du temps de parole des
douze candidats à la présidentielle qui
devient la règle dans les médias alors
qu emmanuel macron marine le pen et jean
luc mélenchon creuse l'écart en tête des
intentions de vote la campagne se durcit
lors de son meeting au trocadéro
dimanche eric zemmour est accusée
d'avoir laissé la foule scandait
des propos qu emmanuel macron juge
indigne c'est ce qu'ils perdent leurs
nerfs en étant violent en étant dans
l'invectivé en étendant la menace en
étendant l'insultent sont mauvais pour
la démocratie et la république quel que
soit le projet qui porte parce qu'ils
justifient
ce don après ils viennent déploré les
conséquences la violence verbale ou
physique un durcissement qui a aussi
atteint la campagne de marine le pen
lors d'un déplacement en guadeloupe la
candidate du rassemblement national a
été prise à partie alors qu'elle
répondait à une interview je ne
reculerait pas devant les agitations
d'extrême gauche je ne recule pas devant
les provocations
devant la violence devant l'aele à
quelques jours du premier tour une
certaine fébrilité s'est emparée des
candidats et de leurs partisans
car jamais les indécis n'ont été aussi
nombreux avant une élection
présidentielle
et on revient sur les événements forts
de ce week-end et on se projette aussi
autour des dynamiques de campagne des
candidats des dix candidats avec mes
invités anne charlotte bezina bonsoir
bien si vous êtes maître de conférences
en droit public albert et nous bonsoir
bienvenue vous aussi rédacteur en chef
du service politique du figaro j'ai
accueilli allemand pierre latry monsois
chef de groupe chez ipsos et matthieu
croissandeau éditorialiste politique
bonsoir bonsoir
mathieu on a on a pris les mêmes
couleurs ce week-end et nos maquilleuse
respectives ont eu beaucoup de boulot
mais on va s'en sortir merci d'être à
mathieu allez on redevient sérieux
qu'est ce que vous retenez les uns et
les autres de ce week-end politique anne
charline bezina je vais être honnête ce
que j'ai dis juste avant que l'émission
démarre on va faire un zoom zemmour dans
peu de temps donc aller en dehors d'eric
zemmour et de son meeting moi je retiens
le retour du meeting qui est quand même
un élément de campagne classique mais
très important et c'est vrai que cette
campagne elle a défié toutes les
chroniques parce que précisément elle
s'est fait dans aucun code en fait il ya
eu la déconnexion avec la coved 19 ya eu
la déconnexion avec la guerre en ukraine
et donc on a eu le sentiment qu'on
changer de méthode qu'on change et
peut-être aussi un petit peu les
habitudes et moi je pense que c'est
assez sain que cette
démocratie de contact en fait et arrive
dans notre campagne présidentielle et
peut-être que voilà l annonce de cette
campagne officielle va à nouveau
cristallisée les choses avec le fait
d'aller directement au contact des
français leur proposer des choses et je
trouve que voilà ce que j'en retiens
c'est ce retour très vème république du
rôle du chef d'état qui voilà qui
incarne ce contact le retour des
meetings albert et nous mêmes questions
se détendent espérer
le retour du meeting c'est ce qui c'est
ce qui a marqué tout ce week-end est ce
qui a manqué pendant tout début de
campagne et qui va peut-être reprendre
un peu de peu embêtant parce qu'il nous
reste de 73 jours mais c'est vrai que il
aura manqué dans cette campagne ce
contact avec le public alors certains
union ils sont parvenus quand même donc
examu malgré tout à fait des grands
meetings marine le pen elle a fait des
plus petits
jean luc mélenchon 6 etc on a
l'impression qu'ils jouent les mêmes ils
cochent les mêmes casque pour sa
campagne d'il ya cinq ans oui tout à
fait et il va dans les mêmes villes par
exemple peut faire ipcress est allé on a
fait aux
graffitis déplacement à hem figaro on
s'est aperçu que par leur père est allé
que pratiquement que dans des villes de
droite et mélenchon bon coup dans
beaucoup de villes de gauche donc chacun
c'est sur ses terres campagne de premier
tour sable après tout il s'agit de
lasbordes mobilier son électorat et ça
roule à vue mais mais on voit que au
moins le meeting revient en force et
c'est je pense que c'est important pas
seulement pour la démocratie mais même
pour le pour la vie collective et pour
que les français puissent se faire dès
leur opinion effectivement on parle
souvent de cristallisation on dit
qu'elle est de plus en plus tardives
alors on va s'appuyer pierre latry sur
votre dernière enquête avec le cevipof
et on ressort les intentions de vote au
premier tour avec un emmanuel macron à
28% marine le pen a dit cet ennemi jean
luc mélenchon qui arrive en troisième
position à 14% et l'eczéma aux ennemis
valérie pécresse a dit non on a choisi
de mettre en avant pour l'instant les
cinq premiers ce qui nous intéresse
toujours c'est les enseignements en
terme de
dynamique de tendance sur sur ces
derniers jours ces dernières semaines et
puis je voudrais vous faire réagir sur
la une de nos confrères du monde qui
titre sur la bataille des trois vote
utile est ce que c'est ce que vous
sentez vraiment monté là depuis quelques
jours oui absolument c'est ce qu'on sent
monter dans le sens où on voit très bien
que alors emmanuel macron s'était déjà
dégagé du reste de ses opposants on voit
que marine le pen monte beaucoup que le
jean luc mélenchon ces derniers jours
aussi a vraiment une dynamique très
forte en sa faveur et que valérie
pécresse et eric zemmour se retrouve un
peu plus loin donc on voit effectivement
une dynamique de progression de ces
trois candidats est qu'il y ait vraiment
un vote utile en dire que jean luc
mélenchon progresse parce que
russel parce que jadot perdre des pertes
d intention de vote marine le pen
progresse parce qu'eric zemmour aussi
perd des intentions de vote donc on voit
réellement que de plus en plus les
sympathisants de gauche se disent qu'il
faudra voter sans doute pour jean luc
mélenchon s'ils veulent espérer voir à
gauche au second tour donc effectivement
un mouvement de cristallisation qui
commence à ceux à secret alors on va
faire ce gros plan sur le meeting de
d'eric zemmour au trocadéro avec vous
mathieu alors on a vu dans le reportage
s'écrit de macron assassins on y
reviendra mais c'est son discours qui
vous a été étonnée hier oui sur le ton
comme sur le fond sur le tour d'avoir si
vous avez trouvé que c'était un discours
de vainqueur
moi j'ai trouvé qu'il était grave eric
zemmour il n'y avait pas beaucoup d
enthousiasme il était sans doute un peu
impressionné par la foule qui se massait
au pied du trocadéro parce que il n'a
pas l'habitude et c'est très
impressionnant bien d'avoir une telle
foule il était peut-être aussi
impressionné par l'enjeu qui finit
toujours par dépasser les candidats un
moment dans la campagne peut-être aussi
impressionné par la lente érosion qu'il
subit dans les sondages depuis quelques
semaines désormais comme si au fond sur
cette place du trocadéro qui reste quand
même le symbole de la loose à droite
eric zemmour doute est lui aussi d'être
emportée à son tour alors pour conjurer
le sort il avec un planté le décor faut
le rappeler rappelant il a dit qu'il
était venu pour précisément laver les
affronts de la droite curieuse formule
d'ailleurs tous les affronts fait droit
je sais pas c'était un peu bizarre et
puis surtout pour placé sa campagne sous
le signe de l'union des droites son
vieux rêve et ce qui pose selon moi un
déjà un premier progrès au problème
parce que l'union des droites ça peut
intéresser les politologues des
éditorialistes
mais ça fait pas ça fait un peu cuisine
politique et puis pire c'est pas une
cuisine qui remplit la cie atteint les
français s'en fiche complètement ou fait
pas élire sur l'union des droits foule
fait élire sur des mesures un programme
une vision un cap mais pas sur une
espèce de deux d'âgés en amène tôt
interne l'échiquier politique à droite
le second problème c'est que cette
énumération de personnalités de l air ou
et rennes vous savez il a fait daffé
saluer et a tendu la main à eric ciotti
à laurent wauquiez nadine morano
françois-xavier bellamy ou à jordan
bardella aura son deuil national j'ai
trouvé que c'était la fois dû à ces
indélicats pour ceux qui étaient là
parce qu'il a quand même des soutiens
062 général ont plutôt ceux qui vous
soutiennent que ceux qui sont pas là et
pas tellement efficace parce que le
mercato on le sait il est aujourd'hui
terminée ce qui devait le rejoindre ont
rejoints et on voit mal qui pourrait
décider de monter à bord de cette
campagne qui ressemble quand même un
titanic identitaire aujourd'hui à deux
semaines jusqu'au terme et il a aussi
eric zemmour modifier son discours sur
le fond ça c'est intéressant oui et ça
c'est un autre étonnement parce que où
est passé de remplacement par exemple
s'il en a parlé hier non où est placé le
ministère de la rémunération par sas
était sortie de sa pochette surprise
mardi tombé aux oubliettes dimanche on
sait que la proposition a fait un flop y
compris dans son propre camp ça sentait
un peu d'improvisation cette immigration
il était juré ses grands dieux ne
l'avoir jamais employé il ya six mois le
jeu à jean luc mélenchon et de jurer
devant michel onfray et puis là il la
sortie mais ça sent désormais un peu
déjà la naphtaline au bout de 2 comme si
les buzz et nous on a duré plus que
quatre jours et ça peut paraître
anecdotique mais ça témoigne quand même
je trouve un climat un peu brouillon qui
règne chez stratège de campagne d'eric
zemmour est-ce qu'il faut clivé ou
est-ce qu'il faut arrondir est-ce qu'il
faut conforter ses troupes à ce qu'il
faut tendre la main on voit bien que
eric zemmour hésiter reese est mon mari
un comble pour celui qui se revendique
est de ne jamais changer d'avis au gré
du vent
vie stratégique auquel on a juste un
virage tactique d'eric zemmour mais je
parle sous ne parvient plus à siphonner
les voix de marine le pen il a tenté de
le faire et puis là c'est bloqué donc
maintenant ils se tournent plutôt vers
les voix de valérie pécresse qui sont
quoi qu'on en dise ou moins radicale qui
sont quand même plus classique à droite
et du coup il est contraint de deux
lycées 10 son discours est ce que c'est
pour cela que lui qui chantait les
louanges du maréchal pétain à lui hier
la lettre d'un jeune résistant avant
avant son exécution est ce qui les
contraint d'adopter une posture plus
rassembleuse aussi pour cela que lui qui
confondait naguère islam et islamisme
chauffage dit naguère c'était encore 15
jours d'ici à une semaine tant
aujourd'hui la main aux musulmans à
condition qu'ils pratiquent leur
religion dans la discrétion mais on voit
bien qu'il ya quand même un petit un
petit changement de posture je dirais le
problème c'est ça revient defacto
ameline campagne de second tour avant
celle du premier tour parce qu'on sait
que dans la campagne de premier tour on
exalte plutôt les siens et puis dans la
sauce campagne de second tour on tend la
main à zemmour plus lisse plus policé
est-ce que ça séduira encore il ya
quelques années jean marie le pen avait
répondu à propos de son propre parti et
au front national gentil ça
n'intéressait personne on se dédiabolise
pas en quinze jours même quand on
s'appelle tous contre on s'appelle eric
zemmour aime ça rien de bezina il joue
il l'a déjà fait le deuil du premier
tour d'une certaine façon il joue déjà
le coup d'après avec physiquement ses
appels du pied à différentes
personnalités
2 deux droites avec un s à la fin au
pluriel le second tour ou même mais même
là
la présidentielle de 2000 27 parce que
c'est vrai que là on est dans la prime
aux anciens de toute façon on a marine
le pen jean-luc mélenchon emmanuel
macron là il y en a deux qui peuvent se
projeter sur 2027 c'est roussel et eric
zemmour à mon avis ça va avec sa
dynamique de campagne c'est à dire qu'en
fait bon il ya des dynamiques de
campagne qui correspondent à certains
candidats qui vont aller très haut fond
des choses au départ pour attaquer un
peu en quelque sorte et qui vont au
contraire ensuite se présidentialiser un
petit peu sur la fin pour être plus dans
l'union et emmanuel macron par exemple
est dans une dynamique totalement
inverse c'est à dire qu'il a joué plutôt
la magistrature moral et qu'ensuite
maintenant il essaye de rentrer dans des
tailles donc moi j'ai le sentiment que
la dynamique d'eric zemmour elle est
logique par rapport à son son attaque
c'est à dire que il ya eu quand même une
émulation pendant tout le moins
d'octobre et c'est sur le fait qu' qui
soit assez extrême dans ses propositions
et l'a finalement ils changent de cap en
effet pour essayer de ce peut-être de se
présidentialiser donc de montrer ou dans
ce meeting que ce n'est pas uniquement
un idéologue et qu'il peut arriver à
avoir cette posture de rassembleur etc
d'où l'idée peut-être de de faire appel
à cette union des droites mais qui je
souscris n'est pas forcément opportune à
ce moment là mais moi je pense que ça va
avec sa dynamique de campagne qui est
l'idée de maintenant jouer la
réassurance mais on le voit en fait ça
signifie aussi quelque chose par rapport
à l'évolution de cette campagne elle
même je pense que l'effet guerre en
ukraine c'est bien plus qu'un effet de
mode à l'international avec les français
qui seraient tournés vers cette angoisse
et pas uniquement ça c'est à dire que ça
recentre le débat sur la thématique de
la protection de l'avenir de l' angoisse
de l'avenir et ce sur quoi ils exhument
on n'a pas réussi finalement à fédérer
c'est que il a il a pu penser qu'on
était dans une campagne où les idées
allaient pouvoir être discutée et c'est
vrai que grâce à lui en tout cas pendant
les premières semaines on a polarisé
complètement le débat sur l'identité
mais les français ont avec cet effet
guère en ukraine recentrer les thèmes de
la campagne autour de la protection
sociale autour du pouvoir d'achat autour
de finalement le rien de ce qui les
inquiète chance laissé la foule scandait
macron assassins sans rien dire ou sans
rien entendre on peut l'analyser comme
on vous est ce que vous diriez que c'est
une faute albert dénouent alors moi
j'étais présent au meeting j'ai passé
j'ai pas assister à ce moment là je suis
par exemple ce que mes mais honnêtement
on pour être tout à fait honnête quand
on est au meeting n'entend pas bien ce
que ne pas entendre alors que nous
devant notre télévision d'un entretien
sur bien sûr peut-être qu'il n'a pas
entendu d'accord il ya tout dans tous
les cas ça devient un fait politique et
et il faut il faut essayer de s'en
dépatouiller pour lui mais je reviens un
peu sur ce que dit à mathieu je crois
que il fait une campagne de second tour
et de premier tour parce que l'union des
droites c'est aller chercher l'électorat
de plus tellement de marine le pen parce
qu'il sait qu'il n'arrivera pas à les
décoller les classes populaires
nationalistes comme comme il les appelle
mais cette droite bourgeoise patriotique
qu'il a en partie récupérés mais qui
cherche à décoller de valérie pécresse
il ya des tribunes que vous publié dans
le figaro 2
de sept leaders de droite christian
jacob en tête pour dire c'est pas notre
trocadéro la droite et nous aussi on est
là droit d'y renoncer à votre book il il
a cette volonté puisque l'objectif
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être plus
tellement gagner la présidentielle mais
c'est d'être le premier à droite donc
battre invalides 20d pécresse et de
façon significative pour pour éteindre
toute contestation possible dans une
prochaine
rencontre position sur la droite et se
rapprocher le plus possible de marine le
pen pour pour l'empêcher d'être d'être 2
par année comme comme vainqueur comme
vainqueur du premier tour et ont tous
aimé mais est en sable
eric zemmour n'a pas affadi sont
vraiment son discours quand on le voit
sur sur les musulmans sur sable il fait
toujours le lien entre islam islamisme
et l'a toujours dit que il n'avait rien
de contrôler les musulmans il avait des
choses contre l'islam oui ça c'est mais
il a toujours besoin d'avoir d'avoir
d'avoir de la polémique devoir du boss
c'est comme ça aussi que qu'il s'est
construit c'est comme ça aussi qui là
qu'il a prospéré pendant quelques mois
même si aujourd'hui des sondages ne sont
une solution plus aussi favorable ça
c'est certain mais il a il en a il en a
besoin et même la polémique il kim qui
naissent sur sur macro assassin même si
on considère qu'il n'a pas il a
peut-être pas entendu enfin ça on ne le
saura jamais mais il essaye d'en retirer
quelque chose puisque dans ses dents
sont dans son corps danse et de ses
proches le disent que finalement c'est
pas plus mal que le président se met à
son niveau en lui répondant comme on l'a
entendu tout à l'heure
macron discutent directement avec avec
sans le citer mais aussi évidemment
nourris donc il ya il y a il n'y a ni
dans tous les cas c'est à 7,1 hors jeu
c'est
cette réunion face à ce meeting du
trocadéro a été une réussite il ya il ya
eu du monde alors cent mille c'est pas
enfin je ne sais pas qui est incapable
de savoir s'il y avait 70 ou 100 mille
morts tous les cas le pari de la
mobilisation a marché simplement il a un
peu terni pour pourrir hexago par cette
polémique sur la croix ça ça et parce
que les outrances n'était pas à la
tribune pour le plaisir on a entendu les
arabes dehors macro assassin d'autres
mots encore il donc c'est pour ça que
vous dites c'est plutôt lui et son
discours mais ces candidats ça y est
c'est parti libérateur ils changent pas
d'idée mais je rejoins tout à fait ce
que ce que ce que dit mme bair il est
fondamentalement le même mais dans la
façon de l'exprimer je trouve que ne
plus entendre le grand remplacement pour
quelqu'un qu'on avait fait l'alpha et
l'oméga quand même mon programme ne pas
entendre ce je le disais ce ministre l'a
promis gracieux je trouve qu'il a
remontré il a montré dans cette campagne
une capacité oratoire qui est assez
exceptionnel oui avec un
héros n aurais jamais cru qu'ils le
feraient ça et les premières
interventions qu'il a fait était pas
honnêtement et et au niveau mais là on
le voit son meeting c'est quand même
c'est quand même bluffant
pierre latry peut-être un mot parce
qu'on va parler de la volatilité de
l'électorat à moins de deux semaines du
premier tour est-ce que celui de marine
le pen est l'un des plus est ce que
c'est l'un des socles les plus solides
aujourd'hui toujours pour éclairer ce
que disait mathieu sur la stratégie d'un
dernier eric zemmour oui c'est un
électorat qui est assez qui a ses filets
de ses fidèles parents qui est assez
solide et surtout à kirill zemmour ne
parle pas forcément c'est à dire que
quand on regarde les préoccupations des
français on remarque le pouvoir d'achat
est la première préoccupation y compris
et ça c'est quand même une nouveauté
dans l'électorat de marine le pen
l'immigration vient en deuxième place
alors que dans l'électorat d'eric
zemmour l'immigration est de très loin
la première le problème d'une campagne
qu'il a centré et quasi exclusivement il
assumer lui-même au début il a dit je ne
parlerais quasiment que de ça c'est que
du coup il ya toute une partie de
l'électorat de marine les classes
populaires en l'occurrence qui ont
vraiment envie d'entendre un discours
sur le pouvoir d'achat et qu'il y
faisait mais on ne parle pas donc il a
du mal en fait aujourd'hui on voit à
capter cet électorat il il parvient à
capter une partie de l'électorat de
françois fillon de 2010 est à peu près
20% mais il ne progresse pas et c'est
fait depuis le début de la campagne il
est autour de 20% et il n'arrive à
capter une partie de l'électorat de
marine le pen mais c'est en régression
donc il ya une partie importante de
l'électorat de marine le pen qui a
hésité entre eric zemmour et marine le
pen et qui maintenant semble plutôt se
décider en faveur de marine le pen avec
encore une fois on l'a dit la question
du vote utile et la perspective d'une
qualification au second tour allez on
avance parce que in fine il ya plein
d'autres thématiques et on va essayer
d'être un peu pas équilibré sur nos deux
semaines en temps d'antenne pour les uns
et les autres justement on va on va
parler avec steve jourdain qui doit être
juste là bonsoir steve de ce top départ
de la campagne officielle
ou alors vous allez nous expliquer ce
que ça change en matière de temps de
parole la change tout ou presque alors
jusque là on entendait très peu ce qu'on
appelle peut-être à tort les petits
candidats on va désormais entendre
autant le candidat trotskiste philippe
poutou que le chef de l'état emmanuel
macron ou encore jean lassalle candidats
inclassable parmi les inclassables alors
techniquement on dit thomas que le
principe de l'égalité se substituer aux
principes de l'équité de temps de parole
jusque là on répartissez-les eu le temps
de parole en fonction du poids politique
de chaque candidat désormais tout ça
c'est terminé entre les candidats
l'égalité doit être totale dès
aujourd'hui et jusqu'au 8 avril inclus
chacun des douze candidats devra se voir
offrir le même temps de parole et le
même temps dans tel que les autres a
noté que les ministres en déplacement
n'ont pas le droit de vanter le bilan du
quinquennat s'il le faut et bien leur
parole sera décompté comme du temps de
parole pour le candidat macro alors
temps de parole temps d'antenne telle
différence ça veut dire que chaque média
doit concert consacré autant de temps à
une interview d'anne hidalgo qu'à une
interview de marine le pen ça c'est le
temps de parole égalité du temps
d'antenne ça veut dire que l'on doit
aussi proposer la même couverture la
même surface médiatique à chacun des 12
camps lilas concrètement on doit
consacrer autant de temps dans un
reportage dans une chronique dans un
édito a parlé du coc bild il paye
presque à la tortue de jean luc
mélenchon jean luc mélenchon qui se
compare à la tortue de la fontaine pour
convaincre les électeurs qui sera bien
au second tour malgré un départ un peu
poussif vous êtes presque citer tous les
candidats mais on a deux semaines pour
équilibrer tout ça les réseaux sociaux
on dit un mot c'est clairement l'angle
mort de la situation actuelle toutes les
règles convient d'évoquer sont
scrupuleusement contrôlés par l'art
comme l'ex csa des chaînes de télé les
stations radios doivent faire les
décomptes des temps de parole sur leurs
antennes puis les transmettre à l'art
comme qui procède ensuite à des
vérifications
rien de tout ça thomas pour les réseaux
sociaux ils échappent à ces règles et
peut-être comme un décalage pour pas
dire une anomalie alors qu'un français
sur quatre prix villiers je privilégie
aujourd'hui internet et les réseaux
sociaux pour fois formés merci steve à
tout à l'heure dans notre second débat
chez mathieu comment vous appréhendez
cette période là moi je me dis toujours
on fait plus vraiment du journaliste
parce que notre métier c'est de les
hiérarchiser l'info se transforme un peu
en comptable en même temps est-ce qu'on
peut faire autrement c'est une forme
d'injonction qu'on va dire tout
contradictoire
on est à la fois extrêmement frustré
c'est une période où on aimerait pouvoir
parler politique on aimerait pouvoir
disséquer les discours vrai pouvoir
parler de tel ou tel avec en remettant
des extraits
et en même temps on se dit que d'un
point de vue démocratique
exposés à un moment et quinze jours
c'est court alors c'est dès 15 heures
les jours c'est très important c'est
pour ça que c'est frustrant et en temps
c'est quand même bien qu'un jour avant
premier tour de pouvoir exposer de façon
démocratique
les idées et les propos et les
programmes de chacun alors ces candidats
qui pèse entre 0 et 2 et demi pour cent
tout est effectivement une fenêtre
d'exposition médiatique
un exemple avec jean lassalle sur france
info
cette élection sera elle sincère de
butembo pourquoi et j'avais mes dents
j'ai déjà quand je la la légitimité
parce que lorsque vous avez coché les
cases de la constitution qui font de vos
candidats à l'élection suprême pour
hommes ou femmes y rencontrer le peuple
sevré théoriquement mathématiquement
logiquement psychologiquement vous
devriez être traités à égalité de
chances je mets les pieds dans le plat à
quoi servent ces petits candidats et
j'emploie le terme petits candidats
albert et nous vous allez droit de
réponse plein de choses vous arrivent oh
oui ces lycéens se faire entendre par un
chacun à chacun joue sa partition me
jean lassalle finit plutôt nathalie
arthaud
anne hidalgo
n'espérez n'espère pas n'espère pas
gagné savent très bien que de toute
façon ils n'iront pas ils ne seront pas
quelque chose mon tour une donc ils ne
gagneront pas l'élection présidentielle
mais ça leur donne au moins pendant
quinze jours la possibilité d'avoir un
amplificateur de pouvoir de parler de
pouvoir d'avoir accès à des émissions à
des chaînes à des radios qu'elle n'avait
pas accès avant donc bon bah c'est la
noble je trouve que c'est une anomalie
jeu je pense que donner le même temps de
parole à emmanuel macron cas philippe
poutou
c'est un peu comme disait mathieu saint
jean sont contradictoires mais c'est
quand on est journaliste on hiérarchise
et on donne pas on met pas sur le même
plan mais c'est comme ça et on s'y plie
bezina presse écrite est pas concernée
devrait pas se merci merci de le
rappeler
c'est vrai que vous l'avez dit
finalement anne hidalgo et aujourd'hui
elle est dans cette catégorie là c'est
quand même un peu le alors on verra ce
que ce que nous réserve il y aura
sûrement des surprises aux au soir du
premier tour mais quand même quoi quand
même et pas seulement pour la gauche
c'est quand même triste de voir que
notre bipolarité où notre kadri
bipartisans comme nos nos
constitutionnalistes aimait à le dire
n'existe plus aujourd'hui on a plus de
débat droite gauche parce qu'on a plus
de droite et on a plus de gauche mais on
est quand même vraiment dans alors la
fameuse recomposition de la famille de
droite et la fameuse recomposition de la
famille de gauche mais on a des blocs
dissidents on a on a finalement des des
luttes qui sont plus celles de de la
tranche sociale de la france qui au
contraire est un peu populiste c'est à
dire à tirer vers le nationalisme celle
qui est attiré vers au contraire la
halle à l'union la fraternité etc il ya
quand même beaucoup de clivages sociaux
et avec une vraie violence en plus entre
les différentes france qui qui sont un
peu angoissante dans notre période sur
l'égalité je vais faire un petit
cocorico nationale mais je crois que
c'est vraiment de l'héritage de la loi
organique de 60 de ces c'est l'idée même
de l'élection du président au suffrage
universel direct et avec cette anecdote
du général de gaulle qui justement a
voulu cette élection pour essayer que
les autres présidents est autant de
légitimité que lui et essayer aussi de
d'affaiblir complètement le statut du
président candidat donc c'est à dire
qu'il avait déjà à cette époque la
vision d'essayer de donner de la parole
à toutes les couleurs de la france et
donc moi je crois que cette période
d'égalité elle permet en tout cas de se
dire que tout le monde est logé à la
même enseigne qu'on a un voilà un petit
panel de tout ce que peut représenter la
société c'est c'est vraiment un fleuron
foncé même dans beaucoup d'autres
régimes parlementaires on n'a pas ce
type de diversité voilà on alors entre
60 gauche depuis le début de la vème
république et c'est quand même assez
intéressant à mon avis de garder ce
particularisme on n'est pas du tout dans
une bipolarité à l'américaine et voilà
c'était mon petit moment c'est fabien
défendons le particularisme à la
française on va parler de l'indécision
et de l'abstention maintenant avec
ce chiffre qu'on a accusé aussi dans
votre dans votre étude ipsos et ifop
près de quatre électeurs sur dix qui
sont sûrs d'aller voter un parmi ceux
qui disent je vais aller voter au
premier tour quatre électeurs sur dix
n'ont pas encore fait leur choix est ce
que pierre latry c'est un niveau
d'indécision qui est plus élevée aux
appareils à 13 jours à deux semaines du
premier tour qui a 5 ans oui un peu plus
élevé mais il ya toujours eu une
indécision forte de plus et l'ex ion
après élection on voit que l'indécision
augmente en réalité à la proche du
premier tour donc de plus en plus
d'électeurs se décide un peu à la
dernière minute ce qui ne simplifie pas
de travail pour les instituts de sondage
mais effectivement il ya on voit cette
indécision progresser avec de nombreux
électeurs qu'ils peuvent changer d'avis
en fait mais qu'ils changent d'avis
entre deux candidats ou qu'ils changent
d'avis entre je n'irai pas voter et je
vais aller voter pour les deux en fait
les deux temps qu'il ya une partie
effectivement des gens qui nous disent
qu'ils vont aller voter qui pourrait
finalement ne pas le faire donc mais on
a aussi effectivement des candidats plus
leurs scores beaucoup de candidats dont
le score monte plus la certitude de vote
baisse c'est le cas notamment de jean
luc mélenchon en fait quand il ya un
phénomène de vote utile on a des
candidats qui vont progresser une partie
de leurs électeurs qu'ils vont dire oui
à priori je vais voter pour lui mais
j'en suis pas encore tout à fait certain
il faut dire qu on a aussi un moment
paradoxale de la vie politique tel que
vous le décrivez serre que le
l'échiquier a explosé et on a les
orphelins ou des enfants en garde
partagée qui cherche encore effectives
ont invité les sociaux démocrates
français ce qu'il en restait enfin je
n'ai manqué de centre gauche qui voter
socialiste
certains sont partis chez emmanuel
macron et cela je parle sous notre
contrôle mais ont plutôt
rare beauté macro et les autres les
autres ben ils n'en peuvent plus voter
pour anne hidalgo qui ne représente plus
que 2 % et alors est ce qu'ils vont se
radicaliser et haute et jean luc
mélenchon parce qu'au sein des familles
de gauche c'est toujours une grosse
rivalité entre les révolutionnaires et
les réformistes face est pas évident de
l'autre côté c'est la garde partagée les
électeurs de droite il est ce qu'ils
vont voter emmanuel macron est ce qu'ils
vont voter valérie pécresse dont 7 sur
les questions économiques ou où j'allais
dire de prôner la droite progressiste il
en existe nulle en france et sait plus
très bien où elle habite aujourd'hui il
valérie pécresse a mené une campagne
très à droite mais quand on a toujours
voté l herbe est ce qu'on peut voter
pour autant et mâcon je pense qu'on est
quand même aussi cinq ans après dans
l'eau dans la réplique de l'explosion de
l'échiquier politique permet de macron
albert zeh nous comme souvent c'est
l'élection va se jouer sur la mobilité
la mobilisation différentiel qui va
réussir à mobiliser ses électeurs on
voit bien que la grande crainte
aujourd'hui les maquereaux nist c'est de
voir une démobilisation de l'électorat
premier tour
j'en discutais encore tout à l'heure
avec avec à un député et des mêmes qui
la peur c'est que
vous s'est jouée d'avancé bas donc tu
auras pourrait ne pas se dépasser pour
marine le pen c'est pareil il s'agit
s'agit de convertir ses bonnes
intentions de vote en sonnant et
trébuchant mais là aussi c'est pas
évident puisque lé lé lé sur une sur une
sur un électorat qui est en plus tôt
abstentionnistes plus abstentionnistes
que les autres c'est bien que les csp -
les quelques airs populaires votre mois
que la bourgeoisie patriotes par exemple
on bat pour pour
pour eric zemmour
d'entente il d'un jouit une dune d'une
sûreté de vote assez impressionnante les
gens qui votent zemmour veulent voter
zemmour il ça pour ça il a 7 il a cette
capacité à assurer son électorat ce qui
est un peu différent pour marine le pen
et valérie pécresse aussi ça la grande
difficulté ça va être de ceux de
mobiliser cet électorat de droite
traditionnelle
qui qui est en train de lui faire défaut
et ça c'est tout sourire là dessus on
voit la part des électeurs de fil de
françois fillon de 2017 vouloir voter
pour emmanuel macron progresser mois
après mois donc vraiment maintenant ils
sont à peu près à égalité ils ont autant
d'électeurs fillon qui vont voter pour
emmanuel macron que pour valérie
pécresse donc pour elle c'est quand même
le signe d'une
certaine d'une grande difficulté je ne
sais pas si le chiffre est encore bon
mais j'ai beau j'avais j'avais j'avais
en tête que
jusque dans l'isoloir il y avait près
20% des électeurs qui ne savais pas pour
qui ils allaient voter donc on rentre
dans l'isoloir
le cap 20% un électeur sur cinq ne sait
vraiment qui oui avec surtout alors ça
ça a été prouvé élection après élection
une une cristallisation de plus en plus
tardives c'est sa sanction et en plus là
on a une campagne qui a quand même
démarré très tard du fait du conflit
ukrainien on peut pas dire qu'elle est
dure qu'elle dure depuis vraiment depuis
des mois dans ce sens où elle n'a pas
suscité un énorme intérêt depuis des
mois donc là vu que maintenant elle
semble se lancer véritablement à deux
semaines on pourrait avoir des
changements de de force des changements
des rapports de force pardon qui
pourrait être important mais c'est
intéressant parce que dans le duel à
droite entre eric zemmour et valérie
pécresse celui qui va arriver devant
l'autre il ya une impulsion qui sera pas
la même c'est une c'est une évidence que
je dis mais elle est importante a
rappelé quand même bien sûr elle est
importante a rappelé et surtout avec
cette problématique de l'union des
droites c'est à dire que finalement on
se dit si aux législatives on nous
vendait une droite recomposée mais alors
qu'en était-il de l'affrontement
sanguinaire qu'ils se sont mené pendant
pendant ce premier tour donc il ya en
effet un électorat kéké à mon avis on
dessine aussi parce que j'ai
l'impression que dans cette campagne
personne n'a réussi vraiment à parler
aux français c'est à dire qu'on a été
dans une campagne très ukrainienne très
fondée au départ on a dit qu'elle serait
confisqué par le virus si on a dit
qu'elle serait confisqué par la guerre
mais on n'a pas vraiment en france et
c'est peut-être aussi pour ça qu'on ont
fait mourir plus vite nos partis
politiques on n'a pas une véritable
culture de l'opposition on n'a pas
réussi à entendre vraiment des couleurs
politiques très tranchées sur de
nouvelles choses alors il ya eu le train
b moins que le congrès ait l'air
carrément pendant trois mois on entendu
parler que de propositions
public 1 alors ils avaient anglais sur
l'immigration et la sécurité
essentiellement en faisant quasiment
l'impasse sur l'économie à part les
finances publiques combien d'heures on a
quand même eu un débat a eu un débat
d'une certaine taille ça va c'est pas
français et s'adresser mais c est du
temps et
les écologistes soient les précampagnes
donc ces politiques depuis six mois
alors on pas message je ne remets pas en
cause le fait que nous parlions
politique la seule chose c'est est ce
qu'on a vraiment réussi à ce que les
candidats eux mêmes une fois qu'ils ont
été cristallisée donc tous ces débats là
c'est plutôt pour moi des débats qui ont
justement intéresser les français mais
on n'a pas réussi ensuite à transformer
regardez valérie pécresse qui sort
justement avec un bel effet de cette
primaire ne transforme pas l'essai
finalement parce que j'ai le sentiment
que à partir du moment où ses candidats
se sont présidentialiser bien finalement
ils sont restés sur le dans leurs
thématiques et ils n'ont pas réussi à
créer c'est quand même très important de
voir que dans toutes nos présidentielle
il ya une question qui a emporté le
candidat et donc l'élection ici
finalement on va se rendre compte que
c'est la question de la protection
sociale question à laquelle on n'avait
vraiment pas du tout réfléchi en début
de campagne donc toutes les choses se
sont recomposées dans ces dernières
semaines et le candidat qui va parler
protection justement qui va jouer ce
rôle de père de la nation pour moment il
se joue entre ces trois derniers on n'a
pas encore une protection sociale qui
rejoint la thématique du pouvoir d'achat
d'une certaine façon emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui en déplacement a été
apostrophé sur cette question la
piraterie est ce que ça peut être le
talon d'achille du candidat macron dans
ces deux dernières semaines de campagne
cette thématique précise ça pourrait
l'être la seule chose c'est qu'on a ce
que lui pour lui les il est comptable
les autres des comptables d'un mur il a
beau dire j'ai mis 20 milliards sur la
table bon bah on sait bien que c'est il
ya la réalité le ressenti bien sûr il
est comptable d'un bilan mais il
faudrait que ses opposants et la
capacité à susciter de la confiance sur
ce sujet là et là c'est là peut-être
qu'effectivement il va y avoir un
problème parce que d'une manière
générale il ne suscite pas la confiance
des français sur la plupart des sujets
et donc sur le pouvoir d'achat ça va
sans doute être un peu la même chose et
ça va être ça le ça va être ça le gros
problème des opposants emmanuel macron
c'est que le pouvoir d'achat
effectivement ils peuvent attaquer
emmanuel macron sur son bilan mais je ne
suis pas sûr que eux réussissent
vraiment à ce site et taxes de confiance
il attaque sur une partie des
propositions sociales puisque sur le rsa
avec une contrepartie on voit bien que
ça ça compris dans l'électorat y compris
même dans les troupes de macron ça
et la retraite à sion 2 5 a aussi
un peu sorti de son chapeau il était on
nous avait promis que le canada qui
finissait une retraite une réforme
systémique pourront mettez tout à plat
et on faisait en faisait le système
complètement là c'est plutôt du
paramétrique à la
traditionnelle on augmente la durée des
annuités travailler puis avait 65 ans
symboliquement ça veut dire quelque
chose et notamment dans l'électorat de
gauche ça signifie quelque chose alors
je voudrais qu'on jette un oeil un
dernier chiffre toujours basé sur votre
sur votre enquête soit seuls 67 % des
français sont sûrs d'aller voter donc là
on est sur la thématique de l'abstention
et pas seulement de de l'indécision est
ce qu'elle est plus ancrée et crs que
ces français qui disent je n'irai pas
voter sont plus sûrs d'eux d'une
certaine façon plus inflexibles qu'il ya
cinq ans là aussi je pense pas qu'il
soit forcément beaucoup plus inflexible
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que ce chiffre
est en progrès le chiffre est en baisse
le chiffre des personnes qui se disent
sûrs d'aller voter est en baisse donc ça
effectivement c'est un constat est-ce
qu'on va atteindre le record
d'abstention de 2002 c'est pas une
certitude mais effectivement on voit que
y'a comme on a vu un désintérêt d'une
manière générale on voit une partie des
français qui de toute façon non plus
l'un d'eux n'ont plus envie d'aller
voter qu'ils n'ont plus qu'ils ne
croient plus tellement la politique
quand on les interroge pour leur
demander on leur propose un certain
nombre de qualificatifs pour décrire la
politique le premier ses déceptions
d'assez loin c'est le qualificatif qui
ressort en tête donc voilà on a beaucoup
toute une partie de l'électorat qui en
fait ne croient plus du tout aux hommes
et aux femmes politiques et ne pensent
pas forcément qu'ils vont changer quoi
que ce soit et se souvient qu'un un
paradoxe je rebondis sur ce que vous
disiez parce qu'on a quand même une
offre politique si on prend les trois
premiers est quand même assez lisible
est assez différente à un changement de
paradigme total chez jean luc mélenchon
institutionnels économiques sociales on
à la continuité d'une certaine façon
chez man elle répondu du libéralisme
économique et des moeurs qui l'a engagé
et puis on a chez marine le pen un
identitaire socialisme
enfin très social en tout cas qui fera
pas en moi qui me frappe énorme ans il y
avait un débat hier entre jordan
bardella et gabriela talent le plus à
gauche dans le discours était
manifestement j'ordonne bardella et donc
on a quand même des projets qui sont
assez clivé qu'ils ne recoupent pas et
la question n'est pas nouveau personnage
et son conte pose c'est est ce qu'on en
a à qui on donne le volant et on va
plutôt d'une volonté celui qui sait
conduire mais qui choisit la destination
se pose pas la question et je trouve que
c'est c'est ça le l'ambiguïté de cette
présidentielle est aussi un élément
important c'est que dans les raisons
pour lesquelles les français ne
s'intéressent pas la campagne le fait
qu'il n'y ait rien de nouveau c'est la
première raison citée ce que ce que je
disais mais là c'est exactement au delà
des risées moi on va dire et peut-être
and wallace ericsson s'est à nouveau
personnage a failli alors chose de sûre
sur la question de l'abstention il ya
une critique qui est récurrente depuis
plusieurs semaines qui est fait par des
candidats des candidats et qui vise
emmanuel macron c'est son refus de
participer à un débat avant le premier
tour c'était encore une thématique du
discours de yannick jadot le candidat
europe ecologie les verts hier tout
concouru depuis des mois a retardé et
obscurcir votre choix du 10 avril
compte tenu du temps perdu
et combien de temps perdu avec cette
partie de cache cache des manuels macron
refusant le débat démocratique
masquer l'inanité de son bilan et la
brutalité de son prochain match à rennes
d'eysines as qu'il se tire pas john
holmes ils sont nombreux à avoir tenu ce
discours une balle dans le pied quoi à
force de toujours dire donnez nous un
mac ronde ans pour débattre ou est ce
que je veux dire il rit alors certes
c'est le président sortant donc il est
de fait un personnage central de la
campagne on comprend qu'ils aient eu
besoin de lui pour que ça se voit là
pour enfin rentrer dans l'arène mais il
continue de le magnifier d'une certaine
façon en dix ans on a besoin de lui pour
faire cette campagne je ne sais pas si
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est
source de la magnification du personnage
de son de son caractère jupitérien je
pense que finalement ce qui gêne les
candidats et ce qui me gênait les
français aussi c'est cette posture de
l'unilatéralité kaka emmanuel macron et
qui correspond malheureusement pour lui
à l'image qu'il a donnée pendant tout
son mandat donc on a un petit peu le
sentiment que le que jupiter est à
nouveau candidat et c'est ça qui est à
mon avis profondément angoissant et ce
que laisse que les candidats manifestent
ici c'est cette idée il a eu
je ne sais pas si c'est une bonne idée
d'ailleurs d'où l'idée de se retrancher
derrière les précédents historiques mais
bon voilà précédent historique on
imagine mal le général de gaulle en
effet en débattre au premier tour bon il
était persuadé d'être réélus au premier
d'ailleurs donc il ya des choses qui ont
changé on parle de primaire à partir du
mois d'octobre qu'on a on a un débat
médiatique qui est très vivant et lui a
dit bon bah voilà je me rattache à ce
président historique donc lui qui avait
voulu plutôt manifesté le changement là
s'inscrit dans la continuité donc ça
c'est un peu paradoxal et puis c'est une
vérité aussi de dire qu on avait tous
théorisé l'idée que la campagne
commencerait quand il serait candidat
parce qu'on disait au moins on aura tous
les tous les tous les joueurs donc on
pourra enfin joué le jeu et donc je
pense que ce que manifestent les
candidats ici c'est cette idée de dire
mais finalement et c'est le seul
président de l'ancien président qui a
réussi à passer c'est pour ça que
certains éditorialistes pas de pain de
campagne de fin d' élections de
mi-mandat presse presque puisque il n'a
pas été comptable de son binaire jusqu'à
présent il n'a pas été chercher sur ces
chiffres et il ya quand même sur valéry
giscard d'estaing en 80 c'était tous les
jours tous les opposants qui du coup
10ème et sur le chômage il a pas fait
suffisamment etc pour le mans alors
maintenant il ya quelques petites
mesures qui commencent à sortir et
surtout dans la période de campagne
officielle j'imagine que là on va encore
en savoir plus sur son programme donc
peut-être que les choses vont changer
mais jusqu'à présent il est quand même
sorti relative
un mot il a choisi un terrible aveu de
faiblesse va par ses opposants ça fait
six mois que valérie pécresse répète son
bilan c'est son boulet il aggravé la
caisse enfin gl dit exactement ce
qu'elle veut du bilan de m macron elle
le dit pis que pendre sur termes
économiques en termes sécuritaires donc
cette instruction process de cette
instruction du procès de bilan elle a
été faite il est contradictoire oui
c'est ce nom mais voilà donc il faut il
faut aller chercher l'adversaire mais la
pure elle a pu dire elle je pense avoir
les pécresse mais à d'autres yannick
jadot l'a fait
le dernier mot pardon mathieu alba et
nous on va conclure là dessus est ce
qu'il faut quand même que la danse et
deux semaines
le candidat présents prennent un peu
plus de risques ce que jusqu'à présent
il fait une campagne risque à minima je
crois qu'il a compris que l'aller les
sondages sont plutôt orientés à la
baisse réussir et ce très haut et il est
même dans les résultats cali
là aussi la popularité baisse on voit
bien que qu' il ya quelque chose qui la
maille la mayonnaise a pris mais elle
est peut-être en train de tourner et
quand on voit les résultats du second
tour
éventuels on voit que marine le pen
monte énormément il ya encore un sondage
qui le donne à 53 47 ans n'a jamais été
aussi aussi proches l'un de l'autre donc
ils rentrent dans la rentrée rentre
pleinement dans la campagne et je pense
que la raison son point de vue il faut
absolument que tu donnes l'impression
que il veille il veut absolument être
réélu président avec et pas seulement
par défaut mais de façon objective
puisque je pars en cuisine mais je crois
qu'une mayonnaise qui a mal tourné est
très très dur à rattraper a permis six
jeux de mots très durs et
merci
à ce débat demain un nouveau débat sur
les les dynamiques de campagne c'est
vraiment ce qui vous intéresse à vous
l'avez compris on se focalise pas sur un
seul sondage avec la régression du
dernier baromètre au doxa avant le
premier tour